que hemos contestado varias preguntas
acerca de los distintos planes que hay
en el estudio de super yoga y lo hicimos
usando las ecuaciones que habíamos
obtenido pero yo soy un tipo visual y me
gustaría ver a analizar bien la
información antes de gastarme los
dólares que tanto trabajo me han costado
ganar así es que lo que voy a hacer
ahora es una representación visual
acerca de cuántas sesiones voy a tener y
cuántos dólares me va a costar y lo voy
a hacer para el plan de prueba y para el
plan básico y para hacer eso
aquí abajo en este eje horizontal voy a
graficar el número de sesiones s el
número de sesiones por mes que voy a
tener y en el eje vertical voy a
graficar cuánto me va a costar
dependiendo del número de sesiones que
voy a tomar voy a graficar se lo cual es
mi costo mensual
entonces consideremos estos puntos de
aquí y también consideremos esta
ecuación cómo se va a ver esta ecuación
cuando la gráfica hemos este primer
punto de aquí establece que si yo
atiendo a cero sesiones y no voy a
ninguna sesión eso va a costar cero
dólares no va a pagar nada como vico ese
punto en la gráfica y viéndolo bien
necesito marcar el valor de cero para
ese que me va a costar cero dólares y
este es el punto cero cero ahora sí
asisto a una sesión me va a costar 12
dólares como ubico ese punto en mi
gráfica si asiste una sesión me va a
costar 12 dólares aquí tenemos el 15 un
poquito más abajo es el 12 aquí tenemos
el punto
como a 12
para dos sesiones me van a costar 24
dólares vamos a ubicar ese punto dos
sesiones me van a costar 24 aquí un
poquito bajo de 25 este es el punto 224
ahora cuando tomó tres sesiones y podría
seguir así cuatro o cinco o seis
sesiones pero creo que con esto ya nos
damos una idea de qué es lo que sucede
cuando tomo tres sesiones me cuesta 36
dólares ubicamos el punto tres sesiones
36 dólares ya puedes ver que estos
puntos se ubican sobre una recta déjame
trazar la recta y esta línea describe
todas las posibles combinaciones de
costo dado el número de sesiones que se
toman cualquier punto sobre todo si
estamos suponiendo que se permiten
sesiones fraccionadas esta no es una
práctica común usual en los estudios de
yoga pero estamos hablando del estudio
superior a donde puedes tomar cuatro
sesiones y media dos sesiones y media o
si tomas media sesión
te cuesta seis dólares otra manera de
ver esto es bueno si no tomas sesiones
te cuesta cero dólares pero si tomas una
sesión si tomas una sesión
el costo se va a incrementar en 12
dólares al incrementar una sesión el
costo se va a incrementar en 12 dólares
así es que al incrementar una sesión el
costo se incrementó en 12 dólares si
incrementamos otra sesión nuevamente hay
un incremento de costo de 12 dólares así
fuimos de 0 a 12 luego a 24 si agregamos
otra sesión incrementamos otros 12
llegamos a 36 si quitamos una sesión
disminuimos el costo en 12 de lo que se
trata es de ver qué tan inclinada es
esta recta si avanzas uno a la derecha
hay que subir 12 ahora hagamos lo mismo
para el plan básico como vamos a
graficar esto empecemos empecemos con
este punto cuando las sesiones son cero
cuando no he ido a ninguna sesión hay un
costo de 20 dólares como gráfica moses o
vayamos a nuestra gráfica cuando el
número de sesiones es 0 el costo es de
20 qué pasa si hay una sesión si hay una
sesión el costo es 28 si hay una sesión
el costo es 28 o podemos pensar que si
se aumenta una sesión si agregas una
sesión el costo total aumenta en 8 si
agregas una sesión el costo total
aumenta en 8 este eje y este eje no
tiene la misma escala si tuvieran la
misma escala la recta sería mucho más
inclinada y este eje sería muchísimo más
grande pero espero que cantes la idea
aumentas una sesión el costo aumenta en
8 así es que por una sesión
pagamos 28 es este punto que tenemos
aquí por dos sesiones
pagamos 36 dólares por dos sesiones
pagamos 36 donde luego a graficar eso
dos sesiones 36 dólares
más o menos por aquí más o menos por
aquí o insistimos que una manera de ver
esto es aumentar una sesión y el costo
se incrementa en ocho dólares
así es que 28 dólares más 8 dólares nos
da 36 dólares continuemos graficando
este punto como ubicamos en la gráfica
tres sesiones si vamos a tres sesiones
nos va a costar 44 dólares esto se va
ubicar más o menos por aquí más o menos
por ahí y de nueva cuenta hemos agregado
una sesión e incrementamos el costo en
ocho dólares y aquí puedes ver que estos
puntos estos puntos también parecen
estar sobre una línea recta también
parecen estar sobre una línea recta
déjame graficar la voy a tratar de
hacerlo lo mejor posible aquí tenemos
esta sería la recta que conecta los
puntos esto en sí mismo es interesante
pero lo que es más interesante es donde
se intersectan estas dos rectas vemos
que tienen diferentes inclinaciones así
es que en algún punto deben
interceptarse y lo que es interesante de
eso voy a dejar que tu pienses que es lo
interesante del punto de intersección
qué tiene que ver eso con el costo y las
sesiones qué tiene que ver el punto
intersección con esto vamos a dejarlo
ahí y exploraremos esto en el siguiente
vídeo